at this point we're going to begin our
executive sessions today I would ask
that you join me in rise for the
Japan
and at this point I'll open the
executive session on House Bill
through D2 FN
and I recognize representative Rhodes to
make a motion
thank you Mr chairman um I would like to
make a motion of itl for house bill 32.
would you like to speak to your motion
yes
I agree with the reasonings that our
prior speaker brought
um
brought this bill to us I understand the
reasons why he wrote it
listening to the testimony there was a a
lot of unattended consequences I think
that will happen if this bill were to
pass a perfect example was if a person
is walking their child to school
I I think a worse situation than having
their gun on them is leaving it in
somebody's yard is there any way to
approach the school so they don't have
it
the other thing would be if you were
going to pick up your child from an
event you would be breaking the law if
you were if you're
um caring so for those reasons amongst
representative would you like to speak
to you a second
uh I believe in the same things that the
representative just said we're going to
make uh law-abiding citizens who just
have a moment of absence of thought into
criminals and I I don't think that's
what anybody wants so
it does have a a really good
idea behind it I just don't think it's
going to work as intended so
thank you I will open the discussion um
if we could make
absolute sure that no firearms or any
deadly weapons at all were got into our
schools I think that would be a laudable
thing unfortunately all this does is
tell people who have no intention of
committing a crime because they're the
only ones who had listened to it that
they can't bring a firearm onto the
school property or near within some
distance of a school the people that are
already ignoring the law in other words
I'm going to murder people I'm not going
to stop just because of this law
if we could find a way to do such a
thing that would be great but it doesn't
so all it does is tell people who have
no intention of committing a crime that
they will become criminals if they walk
near a school with a firearm
like I said if we could find a way to
make the school perfectly safe and we
could somehow get into the minds of
criminals but we can't so with that said
further discussion
yeah
I'm going to be opposing the itl motion
and one of the reasons why I'm opposing
it there are there are people in in my
community who are uh extremely concerned
about this
um they were not aware of the fact that
the federal uh uh gun-free school zones
law was not being enforced in New
Hampshire
they became aware of the fact that we're
only one of three states that currently
doesn't do that
one of the things I think that we do
need to weigh as we make this decision
are all the incidents we've been hearing
about in the media this year about mass
shootings and a fairly significant
percentage of them have involved
shootings in schools where there haven't
been incidents
where people have lost their lives and
been wounded there have been other
incidents where entire schools have been
swatted
so and we're
we're running into a situation where
many parents are starting to run into a
situation where they are uh their
children are afraid to go to school
and and I think in New Hampshire one of
the things we want is we want every
child uh to be able to go to to be able
to go to school uh I think the way that
most of us did when we were kids uh the
last thing I think that any of us
thought of was uh the possibility that
somebody could walk into our classroom
or walk onto our school grounds and and
shoot one of us
um this this bill as it stands
um does not prevent a shooting
none of the bills that we will consider
today will prevent
um uh the possibility of these things
happening
but what we can do is we can reduce the
risk the risk and close the window a
little bit and every one of these things
that we pass we close the window a
little bit and we reduce the level of
risk
um this is something that I think we owe
our kids and we owe our teachers many
other states do it
thank you for the discussion
representative salik
thank you very much
um I also will be opposing the move to
itl
um I was a teacher during Columbine I
taught in Maryland and I taught during
the time of the DC sniper and if you
aren't familiar with that it was people
literally driving around
in a car with a long-range Gun and
shooting people at schools and shooting
people at gas stations and grocery
stores
um and was in lockdown in our school for
weeks
and now I have two students in high
school who've never known A Year Without
a school shooting they were
in preschool and Elementary School for
Sandy Hook
they were in middle school for Parkland
um and the number of shootings that they
have have lived through
has led to a few different things to
happen for my kids and for their peers
um one is that my 17 year old who weighs
all of a hundred pounds walks into every
single classroom and every room she goes
into on a daily basis
looking first for where are the exits
where are the hiding places
where are the projectiles and who in the
room is more important than she is so
she can throw her body in front of them
when a shooter comes in
that's how she lives her life as a 17
year old instead of focusing on you know
statistics and history and everything
else that's what comes to the front of
her mind at the beginning
um it's it's not fair to our kids our
kids are begging us
begging us and their parents and other
parents and parents in my community
including one who lost a nephew in the
Oxford school shootings last uh two
years ago
are begging us to take action so yes
it's true We Can't Stop every criminal
we'll never stop every criminal we'll
never stop every sociopath
who's out there
it's not possible but what we can do is
take incremental steps to make things
safer
and it's crucial that we do whatever it
takes to protect our kids to find
whatever steps we can so that if someone
does walk into school with a gun
they are removed from the building where
the gun is removed from them to to give
our kids a better chance of surviving
I would I would respond to several of
the comments I just want to make it
clear the current state of law in New
Hampshire
is that
the only way you can carry a firearm
onto school property is if you have a
license to carry a firearm currently in
New Hampshire we are at What's called
the Constitutional carry state so the
vast majority of people no longer carry
licenses to carry firearms unless they
intend to travel out of the state for
reciprocity reasons so
to be able to actually the way the law
is now you have to get the license to
carry which requires a background check
by the local police chief so it's not
like just everyone is able under the
current law to walk into the school
with a firearm and and secondly to to
the things that you just said and that
representative you said which are
absolutely
true and and laudable but if this bill
became magically law tonight it would
not change the fact that children would
still have to worry and we have to
address the problem of violence in this
society and stop focusing on the
inanimate object because what we've done
is we will say it's illegal to bring
that in there again I go back to the
person who wants to hurt children in
that school doesn't care what law we
pass
that's an interesting ringtone
I would just say that I I've been I've
actually been contacted by three
School teachers in one of the districts
that I represent here in this house
um I can't disclose and I won't disclose
who they are and they told me that they
carry a firearm to school as a teacher
and they are doing it to protect their
students if this bill were to pass into
law we'd be stripping them of that right
to defend themselves and and others as
we guarantee them in article 2A of our
constitution
secondary to that
I'm a volunteer a compensated volunteer
for my local
emergency management office and we
recently had a drill at one of our
schools in my district again I won't
disclose which
where
the scenario was that
our local Department of Public Works
would send their trucks to block
entrances and exits of the school
and when the drill came to to be it was
found out that three out of the five
Department of Public Works employees
were carrying firearms to defend
themselves and others if this law were
to pass I'm sorry this bill were to pass
into law those three DPW workers would
not be able to carry a firearm to defend
themselves and others so I I definitely
am supporting the itl recommendation
representative Stone thank you Mr chair
what I do know is that criminals don't
follow laws and that's why they're
criminals and I don't see any logic in
disarming law-abiding citizens
to have a feel good and make soft
targets of our schools in addition a lot
of communities have schools that have
their zones uh posted in a lot of
residential areas as well
which presents a problem the federal
government established the school zones
as a separate charging document when it
comes to enhanced Firearms violations
and at the end of the day I just I will
thank you and also as a reminder this
bill would make a thousand foot buffer
zone if you ever look at a map that's a
huge distance that this would swoop into
and cover people
um that they wouldn't be legally allowed
to carry their firearm and
thank you
I'm reminded of the disc
we had on um
the bill about
um warrants
um when someone's hunting
and if I remember correctly one of the I
think one of the things that
bring true with a lot of us is the idea
that there are areas that are the
commons and there are certain agreements
that you make
um when you step in Step foot in
um certain places and I understand and
definitely to a large extent agree with
the idea that criminals don't follow
laws but we don't have laws in place to
tell people what not to do we have laws
in place to provide Justice when they
violate them
and that's the entire reason for having
laws against behaviors that we find
unacceptable in our society
um if if we only made laws against
just the the
reasoning there is like kind of makes me
want to laugh the idea that you would
only
Implement a law if you thought someone
would follow it but not if you didn't
think they would follow it kind of
negates the existence of this entire
building and all of our positions
but circular reasoning can do that to
you
uh I think it I think that if we're
going for example if we're going to have
properties where we permit people to
hunt than it is incumbent upon the state
to ensure that the wildlife is managed
in a way where the animals can continue
reproducing a sufficient number where
they're still available for hunting in
the future right I think that's
reasonable and similarly
um any other public publicly available
or publicly accessible property needs to
be managed responsibly by the government
if it wants to have those kinds of
entities
so I'll be opposing the itl thank you
thank you
um I would just respond and say that
laws are are indeed designed to punish
those who would but they also are
designed for a deterrent effect so it
it's not necessarily circular logic I
believe that having a law in place
deters people from breaking the law as
much as it is for punishing the people
who do it
um representative Newman
so we've talked we've talked a lot about
this law and I I just want to remind
people and I found this out because I
found out and and reviewed the current
law that talks about
what is constitutional and what is not
constitutional it's called New York
State Rifle and Pistol Association
versus Bruin
and it was in uh it's several months ago
that this was passed
and there is no constitutional right to
carry firearms into
sensitive buildings and it says in in
the Court decisions specifically Schools
and Government buildings
so there is enough there is not a
constitutional protection for that
and that's why the federal state law the
federal thousand foot regulation has not
been overturned by the courts
so and we've talked about how do we
protect the random citizen that goes
into a school just in case there might
be a
heat they might be assaulted in the
school
so if you want to test the EXP the
exceptions to the rule then pass a law
and put the court test on it
and see if it's constitutional or not
that's why listening to this rule is
that this law is constitutional we heard
a lot of that when we had the public
hearing I had the Constitution waved at
us and said don't you read the
Constitution this law is constitutional
that in fact
this is unconstitutional that in fact is
a false statement
so I'm going to not go I'm going to not
vote for the itl because of that because
I think we should be passing laws that
will protect our citizens and for the
most part they uh by that the more the
majority of Americans opposed guns in
the schools
but there are exceptions to that because
you can have resource offices and you
can you can write a rule that says you
can have teachers to be armed legally so
they're not breaking the law
and have them take their guns to school
like that and and go ahead and do it but
I will vote against this law
thank you I would um I would um
I would say that so far at least in this
room for during this um process no one
has made the argument that this would be
on constitutional as fact that I would
openly agree the state does have the
power to regulate
um where Firearms are carried in
sensitive buildings so we would be with
within the Constitution if we were to
pass this I agree with you
um there was actually arguments made at
the hearing where people did say that
they thought this would be
unconstitutional and I agree with you
per the court case that you are correct
it would not be unconstitutional
I specifically avoided saying it was
anybody in this room because I've never
heard any testimony like that today very
good thank you I appreciate it okay at
this point I'm going to go ahead and ask
the clerk to call the roll
we are now going to take a vote on House
Bill 32 Vice chairman Rhodes
S I vote Yes
representative Pratt yes
representative Hill
yes
representative
or idealing this yes yes
then that would be yeah
what was your vote Yes yes thank you
sorry
representative jandron yes
representative Manion yes
representative Stone
yes
representative tenzar yes
um representative Muse
no
Representative
bulldogan no
representative Newman
no
Newman
you have two Newmans so no nay for both
okay thank you yes
hold on I actually didn't say anything
yes I'm a no oh yes okay
representative Vale
no
representative Newell
representative zelwig
no
Wheeler's not here
um chairman Roy
nine so the vote the itl vote passes 10
to 9. okay
um House Bill 32 the motion was in
expedient to legislate the motion
carries I hereby close the executive
session
and hereby open the executive session
houseboat 46. and I recognize
Kane um I was Bill 46.
second
would you like to speak to your motion
um I think I feel the the bill needs
some more refining
um and we have a few bills out currently
along the same line so I am going to we
I vote move to retain the bill for
further refinement
would you like to speak to your second
representative sure pretty much the same
reasons uh we do have a bunch of these
bills coming and this one didn't quite
complete the circle of what it needed to
do so I think it needs some work and uh
maybe with some of the other bills we
can come up with a better bill
thank you
um and and just so the committee
understands we we are going to we are
going to work on one of these this
summer and we are going to come up with
a uh a bill so in case anyone's thinking
we're kicking this can down the road we
are not we will be working on this and I
believe we'll be uh making a study
commission out of one of them I believe
representative gath writes and we will
be getting getting a piece of work out
of this committee that can pass
everybody
um representative Rhodes I mean Vice
chairman Rhodes yes and again this is a
motion to retain
representative Pat Pratt
representative Prue yes
representative janvrin
yes representative Manion yes the clerk
votes yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenzar yes representative gathright
yes
representative Muse
representative Bolding
Bolden yes
representative Sue Newman
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes
representative Newell
yes
representative selig
and uh chairman Roy terrible Jess Mr
chair oh so excuse me representative
Newman I think when did you get
um just so everyone knows our people who
aren't normally here our clerk is out
today and I thank the representative for
taking over and so have some patience
with us as we sort out our clerk
situation
so um it's unanimous 10 10. so the
motion to retain carries House Bill 46
19-0 what did I say
oh yeah okay thank you for fixing my and
uh here by close the executive session I
hereby open executive session Hospital
59. and I recognize representative Stone
to make a motion thank you Mr chair my
motion to itl house bill 59.
representative Stone would you like to
speak to your motion
Mr chairman I would the uh
currently ffls are utilized to do
Commercial background checks on all
sales in New Hampshire in addition they
use the Nyx system which is a federal
system for long guns in the state of New
Hampshire all handguns are done by the
State Police gun line which I believe
the cost on that is around 10 million
dollars a year to operate and it's done
by your driver's license number as well
to verify identity this bill really
serves no legitimate purpose in
enhancing safety we already have a
process in place that all ffls are
mandated to follow there is no deviation
from that
and uh
I really think that this is just a
duplicating effort of federal law
representative per would you like to
speak to you a second
that was exactly what I was going to say
that the law is already in place and is
followed in this state by every gun
dealer commercial gun dealer um
uh and if they step around that
there are penalties for it so I don't
see a need for this
thank you
um I'll open the uh
the discussion I think that the the way
the statute is written
um I think there's a lot of issues with
the use of the word commercial it would
uh it would go a lot further if if it
just said private because I think that's
what they're trying to do is regulate
the sale of private between two
individuals and I think that the the
statute
it on some level makes sense but it
needs it needs to um there are there
needs to be exemptions people shouldn't
be at risk or have to go to a dealer to
get a background check to sell to
someone
um who they know or in their family the
current state of the law is you it is
illegal to sell a firearm to a
prohibited person or to someone that you
do not personally know that is the
current state of the law
um I have not heard law enforcement did
not testify that there's an issue or
that they've discovered a rash of sales
uh Private Sales that are leading to
crimes
there is a there is a possibly a version
of this law that I could support in the
future if it was very carefully crafted
but this is a very Broad and I can't
support it for that reason what we did
hear from law enforcement is that we
need to worry about is straw purchases
and those are people that come up and
buy firearms legally through a dealer
for the purpose of giving it to someone
else and that is handled with federal
law currently but it is still a problem
that they need to work harder on in my
okay representative Newman can I just
ask to share a question to clarify
absolutely that is the state of the law
is it federal law state law where that
is it's actually written okay so in
current state law it's illegal to sell a
firearm to someone you don't know
personally the other parts of the law
discussed with the straw purchases is
federal law is the federal law just says
that it's an early the only state law
that I know about says it's illegal to
sell a firearm to a felon
um I believe that is incorrect would
someone
um could someone call up the current
statute does anyone have it handy
chairman rsa159 does state that it must
go through a federal firearms licensed
dealer for a back with a background
check unless it's somebody you
personally know and they are not
prohibited oh could you uh tell us the
statute number again I knew that's what
it said but I didn't know the number
what does it RSA
it's in it's in section 159.
okay and I don't see any contradiction
with what this says it says you you are
not responsible according to the
amendment with the law
that where that one paragraph was left
out it said if you know
you you can set you can sell it to
somebody if you know they are not a
prohibited person
and so I I don't see where this
conflicts with that law at all and it
may not it may be just duplicative
um any further discussion
representative Sue Newman
I I would just add that I believe
background checks and I believe most of
you would agree background checks do
work I don't have a statistic right in
front of me but in the past I have
certainly read and seen numbers where X
number of people were booted out of the
system and did not qualify so they do
work and and as was previously said this
is a Time
because of recent events we owe it to
our children we owe it to our grown
children to do something thank you
thank you representative Newman and
thank you for joining us again today
we're happy to have you with us I um I
agree that no one on this committee
would say that background checks are not
good and that background checks do not
work and currently we believe that
background checks are being conducted in
the current state of New Hampshire law
says that if you don't know someone you
cannot sell them a firearm without a
background check so
and I agree with the events around the
country happening this law would not
prevent one of them
um and it's currently covered already uh
representative salik
thank you Mr chair I I would just say
point out that the purpose of this
specific bill is to close the Charleston
loophole and
if we think about the circumstances of
that particular event and the fact that
I can't go to religious services at my
synagogue without having to hire armed
police to keep our services safe because
of people who use loopholes like this to
buy guns illegally
that we have a problem that we need to
address so I will be voting against itl
I want to recognize that if we use
common sense we should be coming up with
common sense Solutions and not looking
for additional ways to put more
obstacles to preventing gun violence
thank you could for the benefit of the
committee would you mind explaining to
Charleston loophole
it it allowed the young man to who's um
there were hit the time frame for him
getting his background check wasn't
completed and that he was therefore
given a gun before it was completed it
was proven he wasn't supposed to be
given a gun that he had a number of
things this is one of the the steps to
close that loophole to make it so that
he would not have been given a gun
so um just to expound the net for the
committee that the current law is
um the federal law is if you go for a
background check and it takes them more
than three days to complete the
background check the dealer is
authorized to transfer the firearm to
the purchaser
um regardless of the background check
and that is a in my mind a flaw in
federal law which covers this
um and they need to fix it it is my
experience that is very rare that that
happens they are very quick so I don't
know the circumstances of that
particular case
um but it doesn't appear to be a New
Hampshire problem
um representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman I'd just like to
point out if the committee is not aware
of it that there's bipartisan
legislation at the federal level that
has made it uh now a new requirement for
ffls anyone under the age of uh 21 years
old ends up having an automatic
three-day delay then during the course
of that three-day delay there actually
you get a phone call that gives you
another 10-day delay for them to
continue their next research so they've
kind of closed in on that if you're not
aware of it so representative Stone just
for for everyone's benefit I'm going to
repeat that currently there is federal
bipartisan legislation coming forward to
close that and also currently
it is the state of the law that if
you're under 21 years old there's an
automatic three-day delay in purchasing
a firearm and if it takes them longer
than that an automatic 10-day kicks in
so any one of the 21 currently is not
able to get a firearm when they walk in
the store and walk right out with it is
that is that correct representative
stone that is correct thank you
so given the fact that there is some
emerging consensus on this at the
federal level one of the things that New
Hampshire can do is actually
pass a law pass this law in case that
doesn't make it through at the federal
level uh I think uh changes to gun laws
at the federal level have the same level
of difficulty uh maybe perhaps even a
higher level of difficulty than a
legislation like this has in New
Hampshire the other thing that I wanted
to say is that in in addition to closing
the so-called Charleston loophole one of
the things that this bill would also do
is require a background check for for
unlicensed sellers so one of the things
that uh that we have heard is that there
are places where you can go uh online
put a gun up for sale uh and in many
cases the gun is not uh uh or at least
let me clarify that in in some cases uh
there is not about there is no there is
no background check
um and the firearm is actually delivered
uh is actually exchanged between two
people who have no relationship other
than the relationship that they have
online
um
there is also something called The Gun
Show loophole uh which allows a private
uh or I'd say a one of the things we
struggle with a little bit is the diff
the definition between a commercial
seller and a private seller so if you're
using uh an internet website if you're
using a classified ad uh if you're
selling uh a weapon at an advertised
event that actually counts as a
commercial sale it's not the same thing
as selling an extra firearm to your
neighbor or selling it to your brother
or something like that what the bill is
very careful to do is to Define what a
commercial sale is representative Smith
also offered an amendment during the
public hearing when she introduced when
she introduced the bill
that that clarified some of that some of
that language as well
so you know I I think this is this is
one of those things that um I I think a
lot of people think makes sense to do uh
I think the the idea that there are
people uh who shouldn't have a gun who
potentially can slip through the cracks
of something that should bother all of
us especially
some of the members of our committee who
are former police officers
um you know I don't think anybody wants
to have to deal with any anything even
resembling an unnecessary uh tragedy
with a with a firearm
uh so I will be uh I will be opposing uh
the itl and uh and I hope we if the Ito
goes through in the house we will uh
come back with a better Bill thank you
thank you representative Muse
um just look I'm going to talk for a
second about online there's a lot of
talk about online we hear from people um
I myself sold a firearm online the
hunting rifle that I no longer use I
regret it because you should just never
sell firearms because you can regret it
um to use the website called um
gunbroker.com
you list the weapon you sell the weapon
someone bids on it or buys it
and what has to it's very very strict
what has to happen is the firearm has to
be sent by me to a licensed firearm
dealer in whatever state that person's
in
that person then has to go pick up the
firearm I sold from the Firearms dealer
and get a background check if they don't
or if they fail it the farm gets sent
back to me and the sale does not proceed
um that's and there's other companies
you can buy directly online from
um I've bought several from a place
called grab a gun and you go online you
look at a firearm you make the purchase
they don't sell the you the firearm they
send it to an FFL in your state
and you have to go there to pick up the
firearm where you get a background check
so there may be websites like a
Craigslist type of thing where people
are doing that but it's illegal first of
all federally to transfer a firearm like
that to someone not in your state
and it's already it's already covered
they're already doing the background
check and anyone who's not doing it is
is doing a legal sale currently under
federal law
um and as far as the Gun Show loophole
goes
if you go to a gun show
99.9 of the people at gun shows are ffls
selling their Wares at the gun show and
when you find a gun you like at a gun
show they do a background check on the
spot they call the FBI they run it to
give it through if there's someone there
privately selling Firearms
um and they don't have an FFL and they
don't conduct a background check first
of all it's illegal to sell a handgun to
someone from another state without going
through an FFL
um so and the people who run the gun
shows are very strict because they lose
their ability to run these shows so if
there's a one-off on the side sale at a
gun show it's not really a Gun Show
loophole it's just a someone's breaking
the law the current state of the law the
gun show is if you buy a gun the dealer
at the gun show has to do an instant
background check and they do
um and if they don't they're breaking
the law already representative Newman
thank you Mr chair and I hope you'll
indulge in me for a comment if I can
make a comment about what you said
absolutely and then I would like to make
my own comment on what I think about
this particular law absolutely federal
agents who do the right thing and do all
that kind of stuff
I don't expect that that goes to like
the other kind of sales sites on online
it may be illegal but people are able to
sell it through Google market and
pick I don't know all the websites but
pick pick not a particularly a gun site
they sell guns online and there's no fun
there's no federal firearm agent
involved in any of that
so that's what we're trying to do with
the state law
and I I don't take much comfort in the
fact that there is a that there is a
federal law coming forward as it applies
to any of these laws because we've all
seen in the laws that have been
submitted to this house this year are
the Nullification laws that that we
shall not spend any money enforcing
federal laws so I think that for us to
do what is common sense and sensible so
that we will have mirror laws because
that's the term they use in those laws
we need to have these mirror laws that
cover face to cover federal law so that
we can then enforce them instead of
having to deal with these nullification
laws thank you
thank you representative Newman
representative salic
thank you um chairman Roy earlier you
slight could withdraw the motion to itl
and retain this bill so that we can
tweak the language with the bipartisan
group to come up with language we can
all agree with so that we can make
change and pass this bill
thank you at this point um I believe
that the law needs a little bit more
than a tweak it needs a thorough
rewriting examination that would require
a subcommittee which I wouldn't oppose
to unfortunately the calendar would not
agree with that I'm up against it I have
a week to get these bills out and
reports written so
the current motion has to stand as it is
which is ideal representative Cameron
thank you Mr chairman and I wanted to
clarify I'm reading from RSA 15914
um and Prada 14 is all of the ways that
a person in New Hampshire can become
licensed to sell firearms
and requiring and it speaks to selling
to minors who may be Hunters
speaks to the straw purchase you spoke
of earlier if it's a parent they can
purchase it and give it to the child as
long as they have a hunting license
um penalties for violating the law but
to go into 14 it says None of the
provisions of this chapter so prohibit
an individual not licensed under the
provisions who is not engaged in the
business of selling pistols
I'm going to skip a few because it's
very wordy under this chapter or to a
person and personally known to them so
to go to the gun show you're correct it
is a it's a violation of law under the
federal statute as well as state statute
for them to do that at a gun show in a
former life I worked for two retailers
that sold firearms
um Walmart and Dick's Sporting Goods and
I was one of those responsible persons
that was listed on the FFL so that I
could sell firearms unsupervised and I
will tell you that never have I ever
sold a firearm that it did not go
through
a federal firearms licensee with a
background investigation with one
exception my son's birthday last year I
I gifted him a pistol
and I brought him to an FFL for a
thank you at this point I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the roll
thank you Mr chairman and the motion on
the floor is inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 59
um Vice chairman Rhodes yes
um representative Pratt yes
representative Hill yes representative
Prue yes representative jandron
yes representative Manion yes
I vote for the clerk votes yes
representative Stone yes representative
tenzar yes representative garthright
no
representative muse no representative
Bolden
no representative Sue Newman
no
representative Murphy
no representative Ray Newman no
representative Vale no
representative Newell no representative
Mr chair
um yes so the vote passes 10 to 9.
the motion of inexpeding to legislate in
hospital 32 passes I hereby close the
public hearing
I'm sorry yeah
House Bill 59
and experience to legislate passes by
voter 10-9 hereby close to public
hearing on HP 59 and I opened a public
hearing on HP 76. and I recognize
representative Stone to make a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion to itl it helps bill 76.
do I hear a second second
Ed by representative representative
Stone would you like to speak to your
motion Mr chairman I would this bill
would serve no legitimate purpose for
thousands of law-abiding New Hampshire
citizens to purchase firearms uh I know
we've heard some testimony that in cases
of suicide uh Firearms have been used
but also there's numerous cases where
those who are committed to commit
suicide will do it with other means such
as drugs ropes belts vehicles
denying someone's constitutional right
to pick up a firearm could cause them a
safety issue as we've heard testimony
from uh I believe it was a woman's
Supportive Services Group
came in and testify that that would be a
detrimental for a abuser in protection
so at the end of the day I really don't
see where restricting someone's right if
they are legally able to purchase a
firearm should be prohibited
absent Pro would like to speak to a
second
I would so I I agree that the waiting
period
on one hand is good
on on another hand it's bad I've had a
personal experience with a friend who
was being threatened
got a firearm
the next day and the day after that I
had to actually brandish it
to prevent harm to herself
so it worked out well for her nobody got
hurt
the assailant ran away uh
so I've seen it
where it could have been very
detrimental if she had to wait the three
days
so
knowing that I can't go with this
thank you discussion
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman I would just like
to reiterate what representative pru
said I could not think of a worse
situation than telling a woman that she
has to wait three days to protect
herself
sadly
we all know circumstances where somebody
very well may have been in that position
and saying no wait wait three days
about the silliest thing I've ever heard
of
thank you
I'll acknowledge that Firearms are used
often in suicides
unfortunately we cannot read minds we
cannot predict someone's Mental Health
and delaying the constitutional right of
the vast majority of the over a million
residents of New Hampshire
because a very small percentage will use
that right
to hurt themselves it does not in my
mind pass the balancing test
I think that um it's the saddest thing
in the world that people are using these
to hurt themselves with but to the
testimony we've heard people will use
other methods we cannot
um
for a lack of a better term wrap the
state in a plastic bubble to protect
everyone in case they decide to hurt
themselves and by delaying the
constitutional rights of most people
to protect those who may hurt themselves
um I just I just can't justify that in
my mind
um representative who won who had their
hand up
my comment to this is this is this is
designed to prevent suicide it's
provided for people that have a get in
their head about suicide and most times
people know when people are depressed
like that there is a way to tell when
people are are
mentally unstable and and that potential
may happen
and this is only designed if someone has
a gun in the house or has a gun of their
own this doesn't do anything to them but
it's specifically rented to somebody to
go down like we had testimony in a
previous session
where uh a minor went down bought a gun
with a with the credit card
they found out about the credit card
thing they got the gun returned and the
next day he got a gun for somewhere else
and killed himself
and and I will say that I keep hearing
again that you have a constitutional
right to be able to go into a gun store
buy a gun and get it immediately
that is simply not true
We There are waiting periods in other
states they have not been challenged and
that particular
alleged right is not a right under the
Constitution it's silent on it I believe
it's silent and it may be there may be
cases that quote those laws because it's
been challenged
so I just think that
the we know that Firearms are the most
effective way to do it and we kind of
passed off people jumping and people
taking pills and whatever and I think
all the percentages for all of other
kinds of suicide is less than 50 percent
I can get the exact numbers for you and
even update them for 22 because this was
in the previous session
so I believe that this will go a long
way to prevent harm
by having people commit suicide by using
the most effective thing there is to
commit suicide so I'll be opposing the
itls
thank you representative
um I I would um in response to the your
your comment regarding the
constitutionality I would remind the
committee the Constitution does not give
anybody any rights the Constitution
recognizes rights and tells the state
what it can and cannot do to infringe on
those rights and the fact that it's
silent on whether or not you have an
immediate access to that right does not
infer in any way that the state has a
right to delay it I firmly believe a
right delayed is a right deny as there
is no Supreme Court case as to whether
or not a state can delay a right
in my mind you always defer to the right
of the citizen versus the government
but I we will amiably uh disagree uh go
ahead Representative no could I I just
want to ask your question sure even
though that it's not there you can't say
that they have the right and I I mean
people can people can fall both ways
when it's not mentioned in the
Constitution thank you and I I
absolutely agree
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman so when you look at this bill I
think there's a there's a lot of there's
a lot of things I think were meant to be
good
um line 28 where it says expressed to a
lot a law enforcement officer a
reasonable fear for his or her own
personal safety it doesn't explain how
you express that fear are you I mean is
that just is that a verbal fear is there
going to be a form that has to be filled
out
um line 17 it talks about if you're a
hunter
taking the hunter the minimum the
education course but it doesn't say well
what if there's a what if there's a
backlog and there's a two-month you know
waiting period to get into this
particular Law class what if you've what
if you took this this uh this safety
class three years ago right so there's
just a lot of things that as much
assistance was intended to be good if
you actually look at the language that
none of this is explained on how to do
it it for that reason alone is is why
yeah I I would say a bill that actually
would have an impact on the ability of
people that commit suicide is actually
pretty good and thank you representative
verodes for correcting uh yourself uh
from your earlier statement uh when you
raised a concern about a woman who
potentially
would have an issue or might be in a
situation where they might need a weapon
to defend themselves immediately when
you actually read the bill all the way
down it does take into account
situations like that the reason it takes
it into account is we have gone through
a process over a number of years of
getting feedback from people at public
hearings from members of our own
committee and each time we do this the
bill gets better and IT addresses IT
addresses more of the concerns
um
we've reached a point on many of these
bills and this this seems to be one of
them that literally no matter what we do
uh is enough to address some concerns
and and I think part of
one of the things I think that we that
we have to realize is that
um that when we do nothing uh in a
country that has millions and millions
and millions of firearms insert in
circulation when we are not willing to
close the window on anything even a
little tiny bit one of the things that
we're doing is we're significantly
increasing the risk for our Citizens
We're increasing the risk for gun owners
we're increasing the risk for our kids
in schools we're increasing the risk for
people who might have mental health
problems you know might try to harm
themselves
we are not helping
and I think one of the the duties of
this commission or this committee and
one of the reasons why we have Public
Safety in our name is sometimes we have
to make hard decisions like this where
we have to balance rights our own state
constitution and article three actually
refers you know to the need periodically
for for us to put the public good over a
natural right
that's actually in our state
constitution nobody likes to talk about
article 3 but there it sits right
underneath article two
so we have a public obligation to do
both of these things and and I think we
have an obligation to try to come to
balance in a situation like this not my
way or the highway or no change is ever
good
but we have an obligation uh to the
people of this state to do a better job
of coming together on this issue than we
have
thank you
thank you representative
representative pru
so
a little bit about me is that I have
been running the granite state critical
incident stress management team for
about 35 years and that helps uh please
Fire EMS any emergency responder get
through bad calls and handle stress
one of the big things in my pre-incident
education is suicide and suicide
prevention so I do know a little bit
about that and I have weighed both of
those again pretty heavily because those
are my brothers and sisters that I'm
trying to protect
but I also feel
that there's a
civilian population out there and I'm
gonna go primarily female but not just
female because
some guys get threatened by females so
I do believe they have the ability or
need the ability
to get their firearm
and I will tell you especially in my
head
a man who's being threatened by the
woman isn't going to want to go talk to
the police officer and say hey I'm a
little afraid and and I need to get a
gun quick so can I get permission to do
that they just want to go get it and you
know to say yeah I need a gun or
whatever
so I think that might inhibit them
so I still think this should
I understand the concerns of suicide I
really do
but
I also understand the concerns of murder
representative Jammer
thank you
they jacked the microphone up on me so
again I was a responsible person for an
FFL and sold Firearms the form 4473
asks
uh have you ever been adjudicated by a
court to be
mentally
unable to to possess a firearm and
there's a second one about drug usage
um
yesterday
I actually had a citizen in my town take
his own life
and he
went to purchase a firearm and he
answered the 4473 truthfully and was
denied the sale of the firearm
and the person that denied the sale of
the firearm actually contacted
authorities and explained to them
he said something that he wants to harm
himself by the time the police
department got that word he had already
committed suicide so
this three-day waiting period that we're
talking about here
um
I don't think has any effect
I think that the the the situation I
just explained uh us all taking care of
each other when we see somebody in need
we we give them that that help that they
need sometimes we're too late
but at the same time the the safety net
that's in place is in place for a reason
the 4473
does work
especially for these things here I don't
feel like meddling in
making somebody wait three days to
defend themselves others in the state
that's a right guaranteed on the
Constitution so obviously I don't think
it's any surprise to anybody I'll be
and this oh representative
thank you I I don't think any of us
believe
percent
prevent suicide and we certainly can't
100 prevent suicide by gun because of
the number of people who already own
guns or who will find ways to get them
again I come back to people are asking
my constituents are reaching out to me
they're calling as I went out and
knocked on 2 000 doors in the town
almost every single person said to me
are you going to work for gun control to
help stop the amount of gun violence
that we have can you put in Waiting
periods can you help
Studies have shown and I don't have the
statistics in front of me but I can get
them that something like 55 percent of
the people who are going to a gun shop
to get a gun and for the purposes of
committing suicide if they're made to
wait 48 hours in that 48 Hours someone
reaches out to them and helps redirect
them and saves their life
so it may be that we can't protect
everybody and clearly nothing was going
to protect the person in your town and
I'm very sorry for their loss
this bill doesn't say that people
suffering from domestic violence can't
get a gun Quite Contrary it specifies
them as a category of people who can
if we're not willing to take the brave
step and take some action
then we're condoning every one of those
thank you representative
um I would uh I would caution us against
saying that we are the members of this
committee condoning anything I know that
you mean implicitly but still
um
like you I got
um hundreds and hundreds of calls for my
um and and
visits and people I spoke to my
constituents and said are you going to
stop them from taking our guns and
limiting our rights so I think it's
clear that um we all have different
constituencies on this committee
and um I
speaking for myself I do not think that
any member of this committee is a quote
gun Grabber and what I think everyone is
operating from a position of what they
think is best for the citizens of the
state and their constituents and I
appreciate both sides of the argument
and and through US each of us from our
individual districts are speaking for
the people of the state so in my phone's
rings
with that I'm going to call have the
clerk called oh excuse me representative
Newell would like to
um I just wanted to throw in
um especially that
when we talk about natural rights what I
think what this does and the way that it
was explained in some of the testimony
and some of the research that I've done
is that something like this
takes into consideration human nature
and the fact that if there is you know
they call it a cooling off period And so
something like this just kind of I don't
I guess I don't I don't agree with the
fact that you know the the perspective
that a right delayed is a is a right
denied
um I think that in some cases it should
be delayed and that's on on the or you
know it's not harmful for it to be
delayed and it has the potential to uh
help someone uh cool off in the
potential to reduce harm so anyway
that's my two cents thank you and we
appreciate it
um with that I'm gonna ask the court to
call the roll
thank you Mr chairman we're voting on
House Bill 76 with the motion to itl
just um hold on a second just in case
any of the members have a question
um representative wheeler came in he can
still vote because he came in before we
called the question
Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes representative representative
Prue yes representative janrin yes
representative Manion yes
the clerk votes yes representative Stone
yes representative tensar yes
representative gathright
no representative Muse
no
representative Bolden no representative
Sue Newman
excuse me no I didn't have my
okay
um representative Murphy no represent
representative Ray Newman yeah no
representative Bale
no
representative Jody Newell
no representative salad no
representative wheeler
excuse me
um and vice chairman Roy uh cheer votes
the motion fails
and is open for uh further motion if
anyone wishes to make one
Mr chair I move out to pass
do I hear a second
um if anyone wants discussion we had a
pretty lengthy one
um we can discuss it or move right to
the vote anyone want to discuss this
would you like this that I don't want to
discuss it but I just would request that
we take a two-minute break after this
one
that sounds like a very good idea and
I'll probably turn into a 10 minute
break with my magical powers
um Representatives uh representative
Muse would you like to speak to your
motion
we've had a fairly robust discussion
around this issue
um let's get through this thank you
very well said I lost the clerk call the
roll the motion on the floor is ought to
pass
um Vice chair uh Rhodes no
representative Pratt no representative
Hill no
representative Prue negative
Representative janvin no representative
Manion no the clerk votes no
representative Stone no Representative
tenzar no representative gathright yes
representative Muse yes representative
folden yes
representative Sue Newman
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes
representative bill yes representative
Newell yes representative selig yes
representative wheeler
motion fails 10 10 this will be going to
the floor with no recommendations from
this committee with that I close the
executive session on House Bill 78
and the committee will stand in recess
for
thank you 76.
I'm not good with numbers
the committee will stand in recess for
foreign
it's
um
instructions
all right
oh Lord
again
like
foreign
at this point we are going to resume our
executive sessions
um I am going to entertain a motion from
I like the motion to reconsider
40 hb46
second
would you like to speak with your motion
representative
um we had voted to retain the bill but
actually we had an amendment that we
were given and that amendment allowed us
to um
put this into a study committee so I
would like everyone to vote Yes
on a reconsideration so we can put
another motion forward
thank you um I would just say that this
was actually my bad I did not recognize
the number and Associated to the bill
that representative Harry gathright had
put forward that we agreed was going to
go be the one that we used as a vehicle
for a study committee
so I would also urge some members to
support the motion and reconsider this
really doesn't require any discussion
unless anyone really feels they need to
seeing no one go ahead I'm gonna ask the
clerk to call the roll this is a motion
to reconsider House Bill 46 which was
Vice chairman Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes representative Prue yes
representative janvron yes
representative Manion yes the clerk
votes yes representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes representative
gathright yes representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes representative Vale
yes representative Newell
yes
representative representative selig yes
and uh chairman Roy cheer votes yes
motion carries unanimously
um there's now open to another motion a
rep recognized representative here
gather right for motion
I motion to I'm sorry I motion
ought to pass
I mean with Amendment
um
2023-0371h
you're making a motion to pass that
what second year by representative
jambrian uh representative here at
gather would you like to speak to your
motion on this amendment
again
um the amendment
um changes the house bill to establish a
committee to study replacement of bail
Commissioners with court magistrates and
we have lengthy discussions on this um
prior so I don't need to go through that
um I can't you want me to say what it
it's asking for the the members of the
committee shall be as follow three
members of the House of Representative
appointed by the speaker of the house
and one member of the Senate appointed
by the president of the Senate and um it
is due out by November 1st 2023.
representative would you like to speak
um I'll go to the duties in the in the
Amendment it says that the committee
shall evaluate while the bill
commissioner should replace or be
supplemented by Court magistrates and
assess the following benefits and
problems of the current bail system Bill
commissioner system potential structure
of a court imaginary system throughout
the state Court's replacement of bail
Commissioners with court magistrates and
supplementation of the bill
Commissioners with court magistries and
I think that this is a good track to
look at and I think it's a good way to
work with the judicial branch to make
this happen
thank you
um I would just add that this this as I
said is the vehicle that we are going to
use to give a deep dive and come up with
a workable piece of legislation on bail
reform
at that I would ask the clerk to call
the roll on I'm sorry representative
Newman I didn't see
yeah I just have a parliamentary inquiry
about the eligibility of someone to vote
and that would be the representative who
came into the Hall you hadn't started to
yeah once I call the question he can't
vote unfortunately oh he can we didn't
vote yet so he can vote I haven't called
the I haven't called the question so
once I say clerk call the vote then you
can't vote if you come in thank you for
the clarification thank you
representative for pointing that out
representative Muse
one more request for for clarification
essentially what we're doing is we're
replacing uh the entire Bill uh with a
study committee bill
um the language of this bill
um while we may have issues with it in
certain places is going to be really
useful nothing about doing this
precludes us from using this language
again in a different Bill am I correct
in assuming that
that is correct the my goal in retaining
all these bills was preserving the
issues
um were we to itl one of them and we
would not be able to use a similar bill
or a bill with similar language so I'm
trying to preserve all these for the
capability to be used again
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
um Bolden
for the benefit of the whole committee I
have to expand a little on the when you
can
you can by the time the chairman
instructs the clerk to start calling
names and writing on writing down the
votes then not only can you vote but you
must just like when we're in the house
and so the structure of the process is
the chair or in the case of the house
the speaker announces the subject matter
and then and invites motions then
there's the discussion debate phase and
then there's the specific voting phase
and the period of time between when the
chairman says the clerk will now call
the roll and when the voting happens is
obviously milliseconds and that's
specifically the period during which you
need to be present in the room even if
you're not in your seat yet and I'm
hoping that if I'm incorrect about
anything you could clarify that thank
you I believe that is that's correct and
that is my current understanding as well
thank you
um and with that I will ask the clerk to
um for HB 46 OTP
Vice chairman Rhodes hold on this is
this is I believe we're voting to pass
OT
uh
yes that's correct Amendment
yes
representative Pratt
yes representative Hill yes
representative Prue yes representative
janvin yes representative Manion yes the
clerk votes yes representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes representative
gathright yes representative Muse yes
representative Bolden yes representative
um Newman
um
Sue yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes
representative Vale yes representative
Newell yes representative selig yes
representative wheeler yes and chairman
Roy chair votes yes unanimous
unanimously the amendment is accepted I
recognize representative gathright for a
motion
imotion HP 46
ought to pass as amended
that's seconded by representative Rhodes
anyone want to discuss I think we've
covered it
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
call the role in the motion on the
um Vice chairman Rhodes yes but uh
representative Pratt
yes representative Hill yes
representative Prue yes representative
jambrian yes representative Manion yes
clerk votes yes representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes representative
gathright yes representative Muse yes
represent representative Bolden yes
representative Sue Newman
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes
representative Bale yes representative
Newell yes representative solid yes
representative wheeler yeah uh chairman
the motion carries unanimously turning
into zero
and it will be sent
for a recommendation off the pass for
our study
um any objection to consent
seeing none it will go on consent and
then close the executive session on HP
46 and open the executive session on
House Bill 106. oh excuse me act 78 and
I recognize representative Stone to make
an emotion again house bill 78.
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion itl house bill 78. entire second
second second about representative Peru
representative Stone would you like to
speak to your motion Mr chair I would uh
during testimony there was no uh
convincing information provided that
would justify this bill going forward
in addition I'd like to make an example
that uh currently the New Hampshire
attorney general has joined in 25 other
states on a pistol race issue
that's currently done in a rulemaking
authority of the ATF
in addition the uh some of these
rulemaking authorities and executive
orders lack due process improper Court
challenges
representative would you like to speak
to you a second
uh pretty much the same thing uh that
I've seen the ATF uh just randomly
change the rules sometimes depending on
what administration happens to be
sitting in the big seat so
it's hard to keep up one minute it's
legal then it's not legal then it's
it just gets very confusing so I think
if we can just be on a level plane that
would be better
thank you
um I will say that I was this is
um not in my opinion partisan I was a I
objected to the previous president
making uh an executive order without due
process to make a certain item illegal
that's since been overturned by the
court ever I object to this President
and through the ATF making executive
orders that don't go through due process
we have a problem I believe with the
Congress
abrogating its duties and delegating
authority to these agencies to just make
random rules the one that representative
Stone just brought up with the pistol
braces the ATF specifically issued a
letter saying that these were legal
after an extensive study millions of
them were sold and then the ATF changed
its mind and said they're no longer
legal and no matter how many how much
money you invest in thousands of dollars
into such a such a device
they said you can either turn it in or
you can pay this new tax and keep it and
as the representative pointed out
um over 20 states are filing a lawsuit
against that so I believe that this law
was passed with the intent of protecting
our citizens from this
yo-yo effect of of rule making from the
federal government
but it is now open for third discussion
representative Newman you have a
question you want to speak
yeah I just want to say I hear a lot of
discussions about executive orders and
administrative people and places
changing rules
this is about laws we pass laws here in
in this body
and I think that it's been passed in
many other states it has not been
challenged constitutionally it is
constitutional for us to be able to go
ahead and pass this law and wait just
like you're waiting for that those court
cases to finish
we would have to have the same thing we
would wait until they are are
challenged in court and they go to the
Supreme Court a supreme court which I
think has a likelihood that maybe they
will fail maybe they will say it's
unconstitutional and at that point I
will have to live with what the
Constitution says today but today this
is a this is a bill that that prevents
harm
and it prevents harm in a lot of places
and it is the harm that it prevents is
having people commit suicide so that
okay
everything you said is well taken though
can I yes save that for the next one and
could I amend my remarks you may thank
I I mentioned this before so I don't
have a lot to say it's a nullification
line it says we're not going to fall
we're not going to pay any money to it
so I'm against this law thank you and
sorry for the distraction and disruption
and delay
and we will we will save what you said
for the next one
um anyone else
representative Muse
and just for the clarification of our
audience at home could you remind us
which Bill uh that we are on now
if someone could remind me that would be
great
um we are on House Bill uh
regarding
um uh repealing a previous Bill we
passed last year
related to State not Hampshire state law
enforcement and federal firearms laws
foreign
thank you Mr chair I'm the prime sponsor
of this bill and I will say the reason
why I filed it
the reason why I filed this bill is
because
of the conversation that just in an
example the conversations that we had
this morning over and over about relying
on the federal government to control
guns in our state that's a quick summary
according to me so if that's not what
I'm hearing then please let me know but
I do think that with the confusion
caused by this
presidential presidential and executive
orders
we might be going after being able to
limit that but what we're actually doing
is really tying the hands of Law
Enforcement Officers we had an incident
two years ago in
Nashua behind the high school we had a
militia that was organizing and with the
laws that we have now on the books in in
New Hampshire we wouldn't be able to ask
those people to leave the school grounds
so this is one of the things where we
have a lot of police presence and we
have people from all over the state
trying to help us in Nashua but really
what we have to do is wait it out
so that's what we're doing for now
so my understanding is that under this
law
and I have read several interpretations
that the federal laws that we're relying
on cannot be enforced and we cannot use
any money to do that
so I oppose the Ito motion on this Bill
thank you Mr chair
thank you for joining our committee and
sharing your opinion on that
representative Harry gathright
I too will be voting against the itl and
it actually made me this bill made me
think about last term when
um
it was a bill to take New Hampshire out
of the Union so I feel that this is just
another piece of that another way of
coming in the back door to do the same
thing
so
that's it thank you
um I can't speak for anyone else on the
committee but I can tell you that um
as chairman I would never support
um that that notion we are part of the
union and furthermore this this bill or
that we're trying to repeal
just to be clear because there's some
confusion in the public and our own
people a New Hampshire lawn law
enforcement officer cannot enforce
federal law they just can't it's
prosecuted by the U.S attorney's office
um so the the question is is do we
they already can't with this law or not
so uh to the point that representative
made about people at school New
Hampshire law enforcement can't enforce
federal law whether we say they can or
they can't it's prosecuted by the U.S
attorney's Office it has to be a federal
agent
the law that we passed was carefully
vetted by the Attorney General's office
we heard no testimony from law
enforcement saying you know you've got
to repeal this it's it's stopping us it
just keeps New Hampshire taxpayer money
and our law enforcement focused on New
Hampshire laws and not being part of
task force and things of this nature
related to these issues we're talking
about that keep changing related to
executive orders and things of this
Nature by these agencies at the federal
level
um we have enough to do enforcing our
own laws as far as I'm concerned
representative mannion did you have a
question do you want to speak okay all
right
um any further discussion representative
salik
I just would
point out that we swore an oath and a
vow to uphold the U.S Constitution as
well as the New Hampshire Constitution
and this is a law that says that we're
going to disregard Federal
rules so I I would not support I mean I
don't support the itl
I think we need to repeal the law
because I think that having state laws
that say we are not going to follow
federal laws as a contradiction
representative again I would agree with
you but that's not what this law does it
doesn't say we don't agree with or
refuse to enforce federal law
we can already can't enforce federal law
New Hampshire law enforcement cannot
enforce a federal law this law were
repealed that would not change they
still can't
um you have to be a Federal Officer to
enforce federal law because if you were
a New Hampshire police officer and you
arrested someone for a violation of
federal law where would you take them
you can't take them to the courthouse he
can't be heard there he's got to be
prosecuted by the U.S attorney
and if you're not a sworn federal agent
you can't even prosecute it the U.S
attorney is probably going to charge you
um representative James
yes Mr chairman if you recall there was
a law passed by the house well it's it's
why now uh that allows border patrol
agents and Customs and Border Patrol and
all those folks
in the North Country to to enforce state
law so there was a lot enabling that
again our state law enforcement officers
are not
federal law enforcement officers and
have no jurisdiction to enforce federal
law
unless
that's correct
I'll ask the court to call the roll
oh I'm sorry I didn't see it I'll never
that's okay
um
one of the things that I wanted to
mention in the context of of this is
um well
the the current law I think we heard
testimony
hasn't really had much of an effect or
an impact at all in New Hampshire
what it does do is it lays the framework
for changes that could have a much
greater impact and and much more severe
consequences
and I think we're sort of seeing the
fruits of that with a couple of bills
that are kind of come before us a little
bit later today
um this bill when it was presented to us
last year I think many people thought it
was a bad idea we were going too far
there were things that were done at the
last minute to pair it back a little bit
and it made it a little bit more
palatable
but the bottom line is is that we have a
we have a national crisis when it comes
to to gun violence and violence in our
communities and and the hazards of of
firearms in our in our schools and in
public places
uh and by
chilling the ability of local uh and
state and federal officials to cooperate
uh on investigations like this
um it could potentially have impact
especially if we expand it uh simply you
know beyond things like Firearms
trafficking and enforcement of gun laws
into other areas where we really would
like to see uh cooperation between
federal and state officials because it
benefits New Hampshire to have federal
and state cooperation around things like
the enforcement of our laws around
Fentanyl and around illegal illegal
narcotics
so
the bottom line is I support the move
or actually I I
will oppose the itl uh and uh and I ask
for the support of other folks on the
committee as well
thank you representative Muse
um I would just like to say one more
thing I was struck by representative
salig I believe it's another Bill said
something about the safety and worries
hiring guards at her synagogue
and that's well taken
um with regard to this bill and our law
enforcement cooperating with Federal
I myself am a Catholic and I enjoy the
Latin Mass I think it's it's beautiful
um having said that I I recently
discovered that according to the FBI
that might make me and the rest of my
parishioners questionable I don't want
New Hampshire law enforcement involved
in that any more than I would want them
involved in
looking at your synagogue as as
something so it like I said the federal
laws just seems to be at the current
time on a seesaw and we want some
stability
but that allows the clerk to call the
role
you're voting on HB 78 with the move to
itl Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes representative Prue yes
representative janbryn
yes representative Manion yes uh the
clerk votes yes representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes representative
gathright
no representative muse no representative
Bolden no representative Sue Newman
no representative Murphy no
representative Ray Newman
now representative Vale
no representative Newell no
Representative selig no representative
wheeler yes
11-9 motion passes in expedient to
legislate
with an 11-9 vote I hear my close
executive session
and I opened executive session on House
Bill 106
and I recognize representative me to
make a motion I move that this bill is
inexpedient to legislate second Mr
chairman seconded by representative
Rhodes I will speak to my motion
um this is probably one of the most
controversial of the bills that are
before us today and it's controversial
because both sides have a have a very
very compelling argument
um the ability to
to protect someone before or prevent
someone from committing a crime or a
violent act before they do it
um is just would be would be awesome and
amazing
unfortunately in my opinion
violating people's due process rights
is is not the balance on that test is in
my opinion is not it's not in the favor
of passing this law
saying to someone
based on someone else saying that they
believe the person to be a danger in and
of itself is a danger to our society
today you know one one group may say
this person's a danger tomorrow another
group may say a different kind of person
is a danger and having their weapons
seized their right to protect themselves
and their families and property seized
putting the burden on them to prove that
they are not mentally ill or dangerous
Stan's puts the entire history of our
constitution on its head making people
prove that they're able to have a right
that they already in the Constitution
says they have
that that that balance test in my mind
fails
um and with that I opened the discussion
representative Newman did I just make a
I don't want to get away I'd like to
have the clerk repeat to vote on the
last one I believe she said 11 to 8 11
did you want to speak on this while I
well I think I did partially
[Laughter]
would you like to reiterate your
previous comments
I'll just say that extreme risk
protection orders are helpful because if
someone in a family or
relative or whatever whoever the people
are that are allowed to make a a request
for an extension of her order
they they pretty much know whether they
are whether the person presents a danger
to themselves or others
and it's not just a simple it is just
don't write that down and hand it to
somebody that usually the law
enforcement shows up they take a a
statement under oath and then it has to
go to a court so it's ex parte the
individual that they are saying should
not have access to weapons is not there
and in Supreme Court cases
it has said that when there is a
governmental need and there is a short
period of time involved that an ex parte
uh hearing fulfills the rights fulfills
all the requirements of due process
so therefore I I believe this
constitutional I give it I say it's a
good thing
and um
I I will give since we've heard stories
about anecdotal stories I have a
relative that that was a police officer
who was opposed to every single kind of
of law that would ever take any weapon
away from anybody
and I asked him about this law and he
said he was in favor of it and it was
because
he did not want he was glad that a
situation had happened and they had used
the red flag the uh
extreme risk protection order laws and
his comment to me which might surprised
me immensely was
I wanted to not have that person have
access to those weapons because I didn't
want to be standing here tomorrow as he
tried to
commit suicide by cop
and that and I that just surprised me
and I just put out put that out there
for information thank you very much
thank you for your comments
representative Newman representative
Rhodes thank you Mr chairman well I
recognize that there's probably not
anything that anybody's going to say in
this committee today that's going to
change anybody's mind
what I would like to say is the
it is unfortunate that if this were to
become law
the abuse that can be had by this and a
perfect example is
a very bad divorce going very very wrong
and I actually know of a perfect example
of this where a wife unfortunately was
not getting what she thought she should
and the husband was an avid Hunter
he at the time had custody of the
children
and there's some very bad things that
happened to him because of that
and as much as I I can understand the
fear as a parent and in a child that you
that isn't ex that is just a thought
that nobody should ever have to go
through and I recognize that
unfortunately as parents we do have to
sometimes go through that
but I also have to say that there is
nowhere else in the law do we take away
somebody's rights just simply out of
fear of something that somebody may say
thank you Mr chairman
that I just want to contribute a little
bit to the conversation in that
um
I just keep coming back to this phone
call from a friend of mine in domestic
violence situation calling me and
telling me that she was at the point
where she was trying to hide the guns
because she needed to leave and I mean I
I hopped on a plane let's be real you
know but the bar for someone to deal
with a domestic violence situation is
it's it's very difficult
um for for someone to to get help in
that situation and I think that you know
at the end of the day I'm gonna err on
the side of
um you know someone being able to to get
that help more easily so
thank you I would um I would just point
out for the committee and for
representative
um currently under the domestic violence
laws you can get an ex an order uh
protective order and part of the order
is to confiscate all firearms of the
person who is the subject to the order
so we currently have that in law this
would expand that dramatically to a
whole bunch of people who can just say
that I know this person and they're not
acting quite right and I'm worried that
they may be a danger in having their
firearm season before they even get a
say and it just again I go back to in my
mind it turns the constitution on its
head and says prove you're a worthy
Citizen and then you can have your
rights and in my mind that is just um
that's just Bridge Too Far although I
agree with everything said about it
would be great if we could
but it's also
in my mind we can't and shouldn't
sometimes just because you can do
something doesn't mean you should
representative Muse and then
representative Jennifer and then
representative
I wanted to point out that the reason
for this bill
um isn't to uh make sure that uh people
who may have fear of another person have
some sort of recourse or some sort of
Channel legal channel for that fear
um this bill is expressly designed to
deal with situations where a person is
an imminent threat to themselves or to
others one of the things that we went
through when we considered this bill in
a prior session and there were several
of us on the committee that was actually
on the subcommittee that worked on this
bill after it was retained over the
um one of the things I think that we all
learned working together and it was a
subcommittee made up of of Republicans
Democrats I think one thing that we
agreed on is that we were going to have
to agree to disagree on some in some
areas but I think that there was
agreement around
um
moving things like like the the burden
of proof that's required in certain
situations under the bill
um I think that the where we wound up uh
which is the bill that we have now is
much more uh protective of property
rights
um than uh than where we originally
started with the bill uh three years ago
getting back to uh something that I said
earlier
um every time we do this we we learn
things and if we get a chance we can
apply those learnings and we can make
the legislation better
what we have in front of us
is very good well-considered legislation
that was the product of an incredible
amount of time uh time and effort it was
also subject to a huge amount of review
by legal and constitutional experts
we are on Solid ground with a law like
this
these laws are are already in effect in
dozens of other states
including States like Florida
um we would not be an outlier or or
constitutional Rogues uh if we
implemented a bill like this
what we would be
are people who are smart enough instead
of reacting to something after the fact
as virtually every state legislature who
has passed one of these bills has been
in a situation where something terrible
has happened and in response to that we
feel like finally we need to act
the problem is is we can't go back and
we can't go back and and save those
people so it's so in essence by letting
this bill go we're basically saying
it's gonna it's gonna take something
like that happening in New Hampshire
before we are willing to act
and what I would say is we have an
opportunity to do something now and we
should take advantage of that
opportunity
thank you
thank you representative representative
this bill would try to take preemptive
measures to keep somebody from hiring
others so I would like to put this in a
different context we just had our Super
Bowl
last week
and
you're at you have a bunch your next
door neighbor has a bunch of his friends
over
and you see two or three of them through
the window drinking alcohol
so you call the police and you say
listen I think these folks might go out
and drunk drive and cause an accident
so the police show up with six tow
trucks and they take your cars away
and then you can't get the cars back
until you've proven that you won't drunk
alcohol again
so that's what I liken this too we're
trying to tell people
that a constitutionally protected right
can be removed because your next door
neighbor thinks that you could be a
threat
without any proof
and so I I have a really hard time even
conceiving that that we're going to go
out and preemptively try to stop crime
from happening
representative Bolden welcome back
thank you
um I'm not sure if I missed a key piece
of the conversation I've been dealing
with some health stuff and it's making
me a little loopy but I'm confused about
the conversation around
um around
the idea that this limits Liberties in
some substantial way it's a temporary
experience and consistently and
historically in our country in in our
system of government we limit Liberties
on a temporary basis in the interest of
justice and safety and I think some
examples are I mean the first amendment
um you know in court if the judge feels
that you're as a defendant may be
behaving inappropriately they can limit
your ability to talk to the media
um and uh or if they conceal a case and
limit your ability to speak publicly on
that case and specifically in law and
New Hampshire in the family court system
um when there's a particular type of
case it's a misdemeanor for the parents
involved sort of the defendants involved
in the family court case to communicate
with the media at all and is that not a
First Amendment issue but for whatever
reason it was felt appropriate to have
rules along those lines to further the
goals um the overarching goals and so
there there is no sense
I mean I think legislators should know
if anyone that there is no sense that
the first amendment is this hard fast
Rule and we regularly make exceptions to
it and when you're talking about the
Fourth Amendment
we just had a legislation about the
topic that fish and game doesn't need a
warrant we just live in that reality
there we have so many exceptions to what
we teach high schoolers or middle
schoolers are hard and fast rules in our
society and it seems
counter-intuitive to argue
that this is the one time that we can't
make an exception when we live in a
world of exceptions and I think the
build system in general is like the
biggest exception I can think of where
you're not convicted you're not a
criminal under the law but you're
sitting in jail not because you're found
guilty but because you haven't even
faced trial yet so it's confusing to me
that that this would be the
the one thing where we can't
operate with the same exceptions that we
apply to so many other essential
Liberties like speech and literally
Freedom itself when you're talking about
putting someone in behind bars when they
haven't faced trial and are criminally
considered innocent
thank you I would point out that in the
bail situation
um the defendant is allowed prior to the
bail being set and again after the bail
is set to be present for the hearing
setting his bail and make arguments in
his own defense and as far as pausing
shortly pausing the Liberty in the
interest of safety
it's a little more complicated than that
because you're not pausing it you're
taking it away you're actually ripping
it out of their house you're going to
someone's house who may have a gun
collection worth tens of thousands of
dollars and you're going into their
house into their home into their inner
inner sanctum and tearing their property
away from them and saying if you want
this come to court and prove you can
have it that in my mind is a Verge tooth
par representative meesh you wanted to
respond to representative jamrith's
comments
I I just wanted to to say that um
there's nothing in this law that allows
law enforcement to do anything without
proof proof is an important part of the
process affidavits need to be filled out
and filed um even if it's an ex-party
process if you are found later on to
have falsely filed a report under under
this bill that is a criminal offense
that that will be punished every step of
the way you know if you actually go
through the text of the bill one of the
things that you see are rigorous
evidentiary standards
um you know only to uh to get a
temporary order but also to get a
permanent order
um I think another another thing uh that
uh that we hear a lot um is that this
amounts to confiscation of property
the property is not confiscated the
property remains under the ownership of
the per of the person who it is
temporarily taken from
um it it does not become State Property
it doesn't go up for auction it doesn't
go up for sale it remains your property
until the order uh expires or until you
file a motion one of the things that's
in the provision too or a provision in
the bill is it um if you're a respondent
in one of these orders and a permanent
order has been issued against you you
have the ability to go and file a motion
at any period time before the end of the
order that would uh that would allow you
your case to be reheard
so there are actually if you read it and
one of the reasons why it's such a long
bill is because
there are so many things that are done
to properly balance the protection that
it offers to provincial potential
victims along with the property rights
and the constitutional rights of the
respondent
so you know I I object to I think it's
very easy with something this long and
this complex to frame it is doing things
that it simply doesn't do
um and what I would suggest to everyone
regardless of of how you feel about this
please take time to read the bill it's a
pretty damn good Bill thank you
thank you it's been brought to my
attention that I'm missing the right
side of the room so representative
Murphy Oh Thank you Mr chair
um
this bill creates what we know is is it
it's a temporary uh restriction on a
person's access to their firearms if the
civil court judge finds by clear and
convincing evidence that a person poses
a significant danger of using Firearms
to harm themselves or others this bill
passed both Chambers in 2019-2020
uh before being vetoed
um and as chair of the subcommittee that
heard this uh bill darnett that session
I know it includes the inputs
um and edits from a number of
stakeholders
this process ensures that a limited
number of people are able to bring this
forward and that would include family
members those living within the
household in law enforcement
this is a tool you know this is a tool
that we have for law enforcement it's a
tool for families to save their loved
ones lives you know it allows this this
a short-term
um uh urpo it only lasts five days in
cases of imminent danger long-term
orders can be longer but it's only that
occurs only after a full hearing gun
violence tragedies mass shootings gun
suicides they're often preceded by red
flags we see them and we where it's
happening it's happening these are
warning sets of warning signs of threats
that we have to start doing something
differently about
this life-saving tool can help to
protect prevent warning signs from
escalating into tragedy
um this you know one of the the concerns
is that herpes don't have due process
and you know and I suggest that that's
false
um that bill this bill contains a a
brief ex parte process to ensure
Firearms are removed quickly in cases
where there's an imminent risk of harm
but that order lasts no more than five
days as someone who worked in child
protection years ago I know we we
utilize ex parte orders to remove
children from imminent danger my hearing
was you know followed as would uh in
this case
um you know there there are no Anonymous
petitioners uh and the burden of proof
is is pretty high
um as far as taking herpes being filed
for Revenge purposes I I think
representative Muse spoke to
um you know statements under oath
um false statements under oath that's a
crime and there are
um penalties for that
um passing HB 106 I just think it's time
um and this tool will provide uh say um
a way to prevent those gun suicide and
mass shootings it was mentioned prior
that we can't predict someone's mental
health but I'd suggest that though it's
true we can't always be certain of the
actions those in crisis will take those
of us who've worked in mental health
um in the in the mental health field or
have loved ones with mental health
challenges we recognize that there are
definitely times when there can be
observable signs of suicide risk
um passing an uh arpa law here can redo
use the suicidal person's access to
firearms and save those lives I just
want to end on in the words of a New
Hampshire citizen who reached out to us
on the committee while embracing the
vision of personal rights must be this
must be tempered by our responsibilities
to each other as a civil society we must
do what we can to help stop gun violence
thank you
thank you representative Murphy
representative Newell
did you
okay
um that was supposed to say Newman
representative Newman
I can add nothing to the excellent
summary that my colleague over here had
made and it's a it's a result of all the
activity that we went through because I
was a member of that subcommittee we
went through every single line and and
it passed it it went where it went thank
you Mr chair
thank you representative Newman
representative salic
thank you
um
sorry school nurse I'll call back in a
moment
um so I would just say uh representative
Murphy said most of what I intended to
say and the other thing is that in
Florida which is a state we know tends
to swing in a different direction than I
do
um they actually have a similar lot to
this and just last year they used it and
stopped a school shooting
um they had a young person who was out
of the schools and was demonstrating and
posting a number of comments they were
able to go and ultimately take
possession of things they determined he
was in fact a significant threat and
they worked through the process to
secure the weapons and prevent another
school shooting
you know if if someone is inconvenienced
for four or five days will we ensure
that they're mentally well but that
saves the lives of five kids is that
worth it 10 kids how many kids do we
have to lose before it's worth saying
I'm really sorry but you have to be
inconvenienced for five days well make
sure you're mentally stable enough to
have this weapon
that's certainly a interesting question
worthy of debate um
again I would go back to it's I I recall
a movie uh it was called The Minority
Report and where they were able to
predict crime in the future and they
would arrest people for crimes they
hadn't commit but they knew they were
going to commit
and
that didn't end well our constitution
like it or leave it
says clearly these are your rights and
to the comment that it doesn't interfere
with due process I would respectfully
disagree you do get due process only
after your property has been seized in
your your home violated
um in in the due processes you come
prove to us
that you're equal to every other citizen
in the country and that to me is is
wrong
Representatives Sue Newman
yes thank you and I hope I've for the
benefit of the committee I will try and
not repeat so much of the good things
that have already been said
but what I did say last week that I will
repeat is I am so sorry we all are
probably sorry that we cannot legislate
good behavior so bad behavior is out
there and and I think that this bill
which I because of last week I had
looked it over quite a bit
people busted their chops to try and get
19 states have it
it apparently remains constitutional
weapons aren't seized they're
confiscated for a period of time until
and as for people it was mentioned
earlier about a background checks and
being adjudicated and whatever the
example I used last week was the person
who was not adjudicated of anything
but due to circumstances that were going
on in their life was absolutely going
haywire at the time and when people knew
it and knew that he was he or she was
trying to get a gun wouldn't have been a
good thing so that
um things to him family members or
whatever wouldn't happen
it's Florida has been mentioned a few
times and I think it was brought up last
week
at the hearing the Florida red flag law
was put into effect after the Stoneham
Douglas shooting
and recent events that have that have
been publicized and broadcast about I
don't I have not heard any expert on any
channel that has refuted that signs are
all refuted the fact that signs are
always there when somebody is looking to
maybe you did
oh okay
um that signs are always almost all I
will say I will qualify it almost always
evident with somebody so what if you can
do something
before something happens in New
Hampshire where now somebody is
scrambling to get a law into effect I
would think that's a better thing to do
thank you
thank you representative
um
I'm I'm I got to tell you I'm pleased to
see my colleagues Newfound love of the
Florida legislative process
um I wonder if it applies quite broadly
um but having said that
um this is New Hampshire and other
states do what the other states are
going to do and we don't do what we do
because other states do it we do what we
do because our constituents ask for it
or don't and it's clear that at least
half of the constituents in here want
want this and the other half don't I
would point out that um of the years
I've been here I have never gotten as
much constituent email as I did on this
I think it's somewhere over 2 000 emails
people asking please do not pass this
bill
um regardless of the impetus for that I
just thought it was worthy of
recognizing for the behalf of all those
people that took the time to send us an
email that we do see those and we do
take those into account
um whether or not we're able to respond
to all several thousands of you is a
different question
um having said that I'm gonna ask the
thank you Mr chair we are now voting on
House Bill 106 with the move to itl Vice
chair Rhodes
yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes representative Prue
I have to say um a little conflicted but
it's going to be a yes
representative Jan Brin yes
representative Manion yes the clerk
votes yes representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes representative
gathright
no representative muse no representative
Bolden no representative Sue Newman no
representative Murphy no representative
Ray Newman
no representative Vale no representative
Newell no Representative selig no
representative wheeler yeah
and represent uh chairman Roy
terrible chefs
[Music]
the motion of an expedient to legislate
carries with a vote of 11 to nine
and I hereby close the public hearing on
HB 106 and I recognize representative
Mr chair I would like to move uh
Amendment
2023-0-555ih amendment to HB 31 FM
do I have a second on the moon for the
motion
seconded by representative Harriet
Gathering would you like to speak to
your motion representative yes
um what this what this bill what this
amendment does is it amends the bill to
remove the original requirement from HP
HP
um 351 that a a locking Firearms device
or a locking safety device be included
in the sale of all firearms in New
Hampshire well I think that's a really
good idea we did hear testimony from
people who thought that the added
expense of that could constitute the
equivalent of an unfunded mandate for an
individual and I do believe that there's
another part of the bill that is much
more important for us to pass and that
is the second part of the bill that
actually would significantly strengthen
New Hampshire's Firearms negligence law
involving children
currently
if a child gains access to an unsecured
firearm
um
there the penalty for the for the
firearm owner only takes effect if
should the firearm be used in a reckless
or threatening matter
should it be used during the commission
of a crime or if it's negligently
discharged
so basically to constitute negligence of
any kind
um
almost
the worst possible thing needs needs
needs to happen and even if that happens
our our law limits our recourse
to a violation and a one thousand dollar
fine uh
I think we've all heard of incidents
where
um some of these kids go over to another
kid's house a parent leaves a gun
unsecured the gun goes off and either
the child who
um who lives in the home or that one of
the child's friends is severely injured
sometimes even killed
um these incidents do happen in New
Hampshire we tend not to hear about them
a lot uh because they really make the
media and when they do make the media
because they involve miners
um uh they tend to disappear
uh we don't actually keep any kind of a
Statewide uh record of these of these
incidents but the bottom line is is we
know they're happening we had one a few
years ago up in the Lakes region where a
young man gained access to his parents
and secured firearm and murdered
murdered both of his parents
um
so you know these These are these are
things that that do happen uh and I
think
the what this bill would not do is
penalize uh Allah a biting gun owner uh
in any way negligence is already a crime
in New Hampshire what it would do is
send a clearer message to people that we
are committed uh to enforcing this
policy we are committed to the safety of
children and that if you leave a firearm
unsecured in a place where a child can
gain access to it
um there will be more severe
consequences than there are now
so I'm hoping that this is an amendment
that we all can support and I'm be more
than happy to answer any questions folks
representative Musa I have a question if
you could
um and I'm going to just say what I
think and you tell me if I'm incorrect
so this law does not mandate any type of
um
locking securing providing any kind of
locks all it says is that if a minor
gets a firearm because you didn't lock
it
and it's loaded or there's ammunition
available then and the miner does any of
the listed things with the firearm you
would be guilty of a misdemeanor and if
the child hurts somebody with that it
would be a class B felony is that a
correct um that is correct and one of
the other things in the amendment is the
original language says Shelby a class B
felony I changed that to may be a class
B felony because I think these are cases
uh looking at it again that that do
require discretion on the part of the of
the court and uh and I would like the
court to have that discretion the one
thing I I would like to point out is
that something that remains in the
statute that I that has not been changed
but a parent or guardian of a child
who's injured or dies is a result of of
an accidental shooting she'll be
prosecuted only in instances where the
parent or Guardian behaved in a grossly
negligent manner manner that is an
extremely high standard of proof we
understand that that
um that a potential legal charge is
probably
um uh the last thing on the mind of a
parent that's lost their child uh
because because of this and we
understand uh that we that it is
important
um to recognize an addition to an act of
negligence there's there's a huge loss
that's taken place in the part of the
parent so the bill doesn't change that
language
all it does essentially is to put
um
some teeth into a law that needs a few
more teeth and and I hope it's something
we can agree on
thank you um this time I'm going to call
a five minute recess ask the Republicans
thank you I'm just going to wait for you
guys
you think I'm kidding
well I try not to but
thank you everyone we're going to reopen
the public executive session of house
bill
what is this one 351
at this point after discussion with the
sponsor and members I'm
I'm going to recess this session and we
are going to take it up again tomorrow
after we um make a couple tweaks to it
if that's okay with everyone actually
even if it's not I'm still recessing it
at that point I am at this point I'm
going to open the public hearing on
house bill 444. yeah executive session
thank you representative Hill I want to
get that correct and I recognize
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion to
itl this
second
represent Manny would you like to speak
to your to your motion
um yes I would I uh this is again
infringing on people's rights to uh
carry firearms whether it's at a poll in
place or at the supermarket or anywhere
else we've seen no evidence that there's
been any issues with people being armed
at polling places a lot of times you
wouldn't even know it but uh
for those reasons I would support an Ito
representative pru would you like to
speak to your motion are your second
yes I would
uh yep so again
this is another carve out where I cannot
continue with my rights because I'm
going to do another one of my rights I'm
kind of having trouble with that so I'm
gonna ital this
thank you
um I'll open the public uh excuse me
I understand I think the the
um goal of this is that um
at a polling place you shouldn't be
intimidated on how you're going to vote
I haven't heard that that has been an
issue in in New Hampshire
um
Furthermore with regard to many polling
places are in schools and as such
anyone coming to the polls even if the
school is closed for voting still has to
comply with the federal law that says
you can't carry a firearm at a school if
you don't have a license to carry and I
would encourage our law enforcement to
enforce that law that already is on the
books
um but I I wholeheartedly agree with
representative proves
um very succinct
reading of it is I have to give up
another one of my rights to while I'm
exercising the other right
again it just doesn't make any sense I
don't know what it would stop
um what it where's the balance on that
what what is the public safety interest
versus telling people you can't come in
here or with this with a firearm on
um I haven't seen any issues in New
Hampshire at polls I have I've watched
those pretty closely and I just haven't
seen it so
um I agree
agreed the concerns that you voiced were
the same concerns that I had but
in the interest of really trying to
reach out and
um and and see why this was necessary I
did hear a variety of stories of people
being intimidated in that way so I mean
excess especially if it is something
that is already on the books and then is
being just reinforced by state law I
don't see the harm in that
thank you um it would not be just
reinforced though because you can if
that's only with regard to the school
and you can still do it with a license
to carry this would actually take that
away and it's further and that's only
with regard to the schools and if you do
have examples of people be intimidated
and it was New Hampshire I'd love to
hear those uh representative
I'm certainly attorney general as well
um
I actually looked at the exceptions here
and I'll read it from the bill and the
provisions of RSA 159 27 shall not apply
to law enforcement officers on duty at
the polling place or to on uniformed
officers while they are exercising their
right to vote or to a person who secures
an unloaded firearm in the motor vehicle
I have a problem with that and here's
why
several times I have served as an
elected Constable for the town of cebra
I am on the currently on the ballot for
March 14th
to also take that office again the
office of a constable
actually is subject to Direction by the
moderator at the polling place
the Constable is not a uniformed police
officer
and they are not considered a law
enforcement officer on duty
because they're an elected position
so there's no carvo for a constable to
be present at the polling place and be
armed and to be called upon by the
moderator to do his job he's still not
on duty until he's called upon to do so
so because that is not carved out I'm
against the bill
okay and no problem with the Shameless
plug for your re-election
you know we just
down a bill that would allow local and
State Police to enforce the Federal Gun
free school zone laws so we're saying
our local and State Police can't enforce
these laws I guess the one federal agent
that we have for Maine and New Hampshire
and part of Massachusetts could go to
Every polling place in a quick circuit
and hope that he can reach all of them
while there are people violating these
laws when the guns are in school zones
the New Hampshire Attorney General's
office is state and local authorities
can't prevent people from bringing guns
into polling places even those located
in school zones as gun free school zones
are a matter of federal law so
we're we're making contradictory
statements in our own committee about
which laws or maybe cherry picking which
laws to enforce and which law is not to
enforce and claiming well we can't we
don't need this because the federal law
says this but yet we're also not going
to do anything to reinforce and support
correct
New Hampshire police officers on no and
no Universe can regardless of what laws
we pass enforce federal law we could
actually
repeal the bill we passed last year and
put in a new bill that says New
Hampshire police can enforce all the
federal laws it would have Zero Effect
because under the United States laws and
Constitution we can't do that we have no
control over that it's only Federal
officers that can do that now I guess
New Hampshire laws certain ones Law
Enforcement Officers could be dual sworn
which I believe does occur and we have
some who are on task force and things
with them who wouldn't affect wouldn't
be affected by that because they're
already sworn federal agents
but New Hampshire law enforcement State
local fish whatever cannot enforce
federal law unless they are sworn
Federal officers because only the United
States Attorney can prosecute federal
crimes
so we're not talking out of both sides
of our mouth what we're saying is
New Hampshire law enforcement can't
enforce federal law
this section as federal law is the only
law of it and this isn't only about
schools by the way this is about all
polling places but with regard to school
if it's a polling place
what I was pointing out is that the law
that requires
people have a license to carry a firearm
to go into the polling place
still exists and even if the school is
closed
New Hampshire law enforcement could
never enforce that anyway because
they're not federal agents it's a
federal law if to your point the federal
government decided to staff that up and
start patrolling all the schools they're
the only ones who could prosecute that
you may respond
just want to say so we have federal law
that says to keep guns out of polling
places and you've just said and we have
voted against adding any state laws to
reinforce federal laws or to to parallel
them as the term might be so unless we
pass a state law
there is going to be continue to be no
enforcement we're going to continue to
have risk the chair Also earlier asked
about people who felt intimidated by
guns at polling places I will tell you I
am one of those people who has felt
intimidated at a polling place because
of people coming in with their guns both
when I was working as a town sworn
election official and when I was there
on my own as an individual to vote I am
someone who personally chooses not to
carry I have no desire to own a gun
because I am well aware of my own
physical incompetence and the likelihood
I'd be much more likely to shoot myself
than to do any good to anyone else
but the reality is that when someone
came up to me and it was clear that he
was carrying even though it might be
concealed
that when he came up and I had to ask
him for his ID based on another law that
was passed and his response was to
thrust his hip at me and say I don't
really need to show you
expletive
that I certainly felt intimidated
and it was because I was sitting next to
someone else who was able to contact our
local author or police officer who came
over and proceeded to stand there and
then escort this person through the
premises
but if you're asking about people
feeling intimidated by people carrying
yeah I felt intimidated absolutely
thank you for sharing that with us that
is that is not regrettable and it sounds
like that person was pretty close to the
brandishing law which would make him a
criminal representative salic excuse me
Bolden
you just call me say like b
um
uh thank you
the on the topic of giving up a right to
exercise right we already have laws in
place in New Hampshire that are enforced
that prohibit electioneering in a
polling place and if memory serves I I
don't I think I I think I missed the
exec on the um
it's bill
um but
uh if memory serves it was maybe last
year or maybe the election in 2021 when
someone tried to vote in a polling
station
um in a town somewhere and they were
wearing a shirt that advocated for
candidate and they were asked they were
told they could not wear the shirt in
the PlayStation in this person took off
her shirt and proceeded to vote because
one was legal and the other one wasn't
and so she complied to the extent that
she would topless and I think maybe
hadn't worn a bra that day but
um anyway so there's precedent there's
an established precedent for
requiring you to give up some rights in
order to exercise another right so I
don't understand logic in that argument
and and that's also and chiefly an issue
of voter intimidation and without a
doubt I think in my own polling station
given what I know of my own constituency
I have strong feelings about the
presence of police at the entrance to
the polling station I understand their
function and that they're trying to
prevent they want to be available in
case there's any kind of conflict
between voters or protesters or
something
um but I every time they're there I try
to engage and see if there's a better
place that we can put them so they can
set their purpose but they don't seem to
be gatekeeper
um they don't so they don't give an
impression of their Gatekeepers and
voter intimidation is and always should
be
um front of mind when you're talking
about the experience that someone has
walking through a polling station
and that's why you know masks were not a
requirement when we were going through a
period of the majority of people wearing
masks in public polling stations were
not requiring it because you need to be
able to feel comfortable voting and not
feel pressured to vote a particular way
when you're going in and
so I think that it's always important to
make sure that the experience of the
voter going in is designed
um to to remind them that they do have
the rights of Voters they please and
that they maintain their right to vote
but I think it's also worth mentioning
that not all polling stations are in
schools Manchester has 12 polling
stations and two of them off the top of
my head are in churches and I don't know
that they're anywhere near schools so it
does seem like there's room for this
kind of a proposal in our current
election process in New Hampshire thank
you thank you I would um I would respond
with regards to logic um I think that
there's a big difference between me not
being able to wear my Tippy Canoe and
Tyler II shirt to vote
versus
carry a firearm to protect myself if I
am not allowed to wear my t-shirt
I might get chilly if I can't carry my
firearm I I may be killed um there's a
difference
but I like your your thinking and I
would be happy to co-sponsor a bill in
September that relates to voter
intimidation whether it be with a
firearm or something else I
what representative salic happened in my
mind
um should be highly illegal what what
you said happened to you and um and if
it's not already illegal enough we can
stiffen that penalty
um representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman I would just like
to point out that um criminal
threatening is illegal in the state of
New Hampshire and the mere Act of
burying your arm is not if you're doing
that in a peaceful manner
that is not and should not be illegal
regardless of where you are
I don't think that that sounded peaceful
what she said she described
I would just like to point out that
there are there already are places in
New Hampshire uh where we do not allow
Firearms
um those are our courts
um we do not allow you to take a firearm
into a court with with very good reasons
um
and there are many states uh who feel
that polling places and other public
places actually fall into the same
category
um the Supreme Court has recognized in
the Heller Decision the ability of
states to do this so nothing about doing
this is is inconsistent is
unconstitutional or is bad public safety
policy
this is one more thing that we can do to
reduce the risk of uh in this case
not only gun violence or accidental
discharge of a firearm but it's one more
thing that we can do to ensure that
people feel comfortable that they feel
safe
and insecure when they're exercising one
of their most important rights as
Americans which is which is the right to
vote and in New Hampshire we
we uh we consume a lot of oxygen uh
talking about our elections the
importance of our elections the
Integrity of our elections
bringing a firearm into a polling place
uh
is a way potentially of exerting control
exerting influence around somebody
else's decision it's something that can
that I know has uh has kept some people
from voting I know in my own town in
Portsmouth when the attorney general
made his clarification a few years ago
and said that yes Firearms are allowed
in polling places under our law
um we had several people who who quit
and we had a hard time finding people to
replace them and we asked our polar
workers to do a lot we asked them to be
at the polls in the time of a pandemic
we asked them to work incredibly long
hours
we passed laws that make them
accountable if they make mistakes
I think one thing that we could that we
could do that would make things a little
bit easier for them is at least ensure
that when they're doing their job and
when they're helping the rest of us do
our are helping the rest of us exercise
our Democratic rights that they feel
relatively safe in doing so and and I
think introducing a firearm into that
situation uh changes that
thank you
thank you representative Reed
thank you Mr chairman I have to
respectfully disagree when um I go um
someplace and I see that people are
carrying lawfully and if there's
officers there I that gives me a sense
of safety my first feeling is not fear
and and worry my feelings like if
something happens we're covered
um so I think it's a matter of
perception and tomato tomato but from my
perspective I feel safer knowing that we
are not a soft target and that there are
people there willing and trained to keep
us safe thank you represent Stone
thank you Mr chairman uh two places in
New Hampshire that don't allow Firearms
or prisons and courthouses the reason
for that is you have prisoners there
that could cause uh you know concern
over the issues of Escape uh going
forward with the polling places you have
a moderator there that controls the
elections of the polling place if
there's an issue any citizen can contact
the moderator the moderator finds it
necessary they can contact law
enforcement at least in my community we
have law enforcement drove in and out of
the polling locations non-stop it's very
common to see people with Firearms
showing up to vote
maybe I'm fortunate because in our
community we have less than 10 minutes
you're in and out it's not a significant
amount of time to be hanging out so I
guess I really don't see the issue with
trying to restrict someone for about 10
minutes of pull time
thank you representative wheeler thank
you Mr chairman
um
all of these have been hard votes for me
and I I understand where people are
coming from on this end and I am not
someone who at all I don't think anyone
here on this committee wants gun
violence or is uh heartened by the news
stories that we're seeing on the news
and the horrific nature of the crimes
that we're seeing I'm not sure that
legislation like what we have before is
specifically for these polling place
legislation is the way to move forward I
don't think we're elected to legislate
based off of how comfortable people are
feeling I think
like representative Reed said some
people are comforted by other people
having a weapon so the simple Act of
having a weapon on your holster in a
polling place while that might make
someone feel uncomfortable given the
news stories that people are are hearing
um is not reason enough to restrict
someone from being allowed to carry that
weapon into the polling place when they
vote and we heard from a lot of people
that if if this was allowed if this
passed that they would just leave their
gun in the car or they just would not
come so to representative Muse's point
about people not voting because there
potentially could be guns on someone
else's hip what about the people who
might not vote because they're not
allowed to bring their gun into the vote
the polling place so there's there's
parallel arguments that could be made to
all of this and I just think that we do
not legislate based off of comfort we
legislate based off of what's good
policy and I do not see HB 444 as good
policy thank you Mr chair
thank you representative representative
Manion
I definitely will be voting for this
bill
okay
um one of the things that I see with
this bill is intimidation
and I literally do and every time that
I'm at the polls and there's someone
there and you can rather they're showing
their guns or if they're hidden it
doesn't matter because you can see that
and not just me but there are other
people that look like me have the same
issues it's like a hair stands up and
given what's going on across the United
States and even what's going on here in
New Hampshire when it comes to people of
color
I don't believe that anyone should have
any weapons there there's a police
officer at every polling place that I'm
aware of and that's enough
foreign
thank you representative representative
Pratt
thank you
for letting me speak
um looking at the bill itself it says
you'll be guilty of a Class A
misdemeanor if you carry a loaded or
unloaded gun
if you open carry or you conceal carry
or whether your licensed or unlicensed
so that means a person could be in
violation of a Class B misdemeanor if
they're carry an unloaded pistol
concealed with a New Hampshire license
and that's a total Infinity on your
second amendment rights uh we can't
protect people's feelings
uh
just a few months ago a state
representative felt intimidated by my
hat I mean how far do we go
how far do we do where do we draw the
line on how far do we go on people's
rights I would be voting against this
bill for sure thank you
um to your point representative Pratt I
would argue that you know we we do have
that we do have that law that people
cannot wear
um
you know things that are
um as as representative Bolton said
earlier things that are in you know
having a candidate or something like
that that is already on the books so I
mean I think when we talk about you know
legislating based on
um intimidation it
it is kind of an extension of what we
nobody okay
um this time oh representative Newman he
did I did acknowledge Him
and and the first thing I have is a
question for the chair and it was the
point you made about that New Hampshire
Law Enforcement Officers cannot enforce
federal law
I'm just wondering who enforces the who
enforces the law about
um not having weapons at the at the
polls
you mean the schools if it's a school I
mean at the courthouses I mean just oh
one forces that the um I believe it's
the court
um the court security
um it's a state law so um any state
trooper if it's in a municipality any
Municipal officer but it's a state I
the other thing I wanted to note is I
mentioned I mentioned the the Supreme
Court case that that goes to uh school
no weapons in the Schools and Government
places and then also in that in that
Supreme Court case
what they have to do is look at the
historical record to see what it is and
they gave specific examples of things
that are in the historical record that
can be protected and one of them was
um I I agree the um that Supreme Court
ruling did say that we could do that
um and I guess my response would be what
I said earlier sometimes just because we
can do something doesn't mean we should
um representative Stone
thank you Mr chair just in response to
representative Newman the judicial
branch has their own court security
officers that have full powers of arrest
at all our courts and at the superior
court level it's done by the sheriff's
office which also has bailiffs
can I respond yes yes and I agree with
you and I was the the courthouse does
not have the same kind of federal law
associated with it that the that it is
so I
thank you for the clarification
Stone
okay
um I I would just say that the
courthouse is indeed um is in law the
the difference I see is that with the
courthouse oftentimes you are dealing
with
um known criminals who have been
convicted of violent crimes
and their potential to have their
Liberty taken for extended period of
times oftentimes can drive emotions of
them and their family members and it's
um a lot a more volatile situation than
whether or not you're going to vote to
increase the school
budget so again it's nuanced and both
sides have a legitimate argument having
said that this time I'd ask the court to
call the roll unless I miss somebody
else represent proof I missed you
one thing I
like to point out about courthouses
that I see is everybody gets screened
going into that building so I'm pretty
sure there's no other guns besides the
law enforcement that's in there and
they're making a commitment
of my security
when they take away my right to bear
arms they should be stepping up to say I
will be safe and by screening everybody
and making sure no other weapons come in
they're doing that so that's the
difference between
courthouse in a polling place that I see
thank you that that is a very compelling
point that at the courthouse you are
guaranteed at least safety from firearms
because they've taken the extra steps to
put the the magnetometers and screen to
okay you can't bring your gun in but
we're going to protect you by making
sure no one else has one either if we
were to do this at a polling place only
the people that obeyed the law would
have no guns and the people that didn't
would which puts you a disadvantage to a
criminal who could have a firearm at
this point I would ask the clerk to call
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes representative representative
Prue absolutely representative Jan Brin
yes representative Manion yes the clerk
votes yes the representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes Representative
gathright no representative muse no
representative Bolden
no representative Sue Newman no
representative Murphy no representative
Ray uh Newman no representative Bale no
representative Newell no Representative
selig no representative Mueller yay and
representative I mean uh chairman Roy
chair votes yes and that is eleven at
night the motion of inexpected to
legislate carries with a vote of 11 to
nine not here by close executive session
and I open the executive session on
House Bill 474 and I recognize
foreign
wow
representative Pro
would you like to make a motion
sure I'll make a motion to Ito
second motion made by representative
Prue seconded by representative Rhodes
representative Peru would you like to
speak to your motion as soon as I can
find the bill take your time hey yeah
um
relative enforcement
um by federal firearms laws um
sorry I wasn't planning on being the guy
but um
representative Amanda would you like to
uh I know that you didn't make the
motion did you say you wanted to speak
on this thank you Mr chair a specific
issue with this bill is the penalties
um and the potential of qualified
immunity being removed from law
enforcement offices I believe the local
law enforcement should not be subject to
the penalties that this bill uh puts in
place there are some felonies involved
there are costs attorney costs for the
person who is being investigated by the
federal government even though the law
enforcement officer himself is not doing
the investigation and and also there are
some due process issues with him being
terminated immediately
upon any kind of Aid or assistance to
federal law enforcement
so for those issues I would recommend an
itl
thank you representative Manion
discussion
anyone
when I would ask the clerk to call the
roll um the motion on the floor is an
expedient to legislate we are voting on
House Bill 474.
um
chairman Rhodes yes
representative Pratt
yes representative Hill yes
representative Pro uh pru yes
representative janbron yes
representative Manion yes the clerk
votes yes representative Stone yes
representative tenzar yes Representative
yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy
no
representative Ray Newman
yes
representative Vale yes representative
Newell yes representative selig
yes
representative wheeler
no
I don't know um I don't know what just
happened
um I'm in a boat uh I'm gonna vote Yes
to the motion of itl I think and What's
the total
um
I think so
representative here gather right would
you like to reconsider or change your
vote
we appear to have stepped into the
Twilight Zone on this bill
okay
I believe we were we were not surprised
by the bill but we were surprised by the
motion and it said we were just
completely discombobulated I I will not
take advantage of that um
yeah okay so we're gonna um I I don't
know that did the clerk leave it would
will the clerk please recall the role
Mr chairman a motion to reconsider has
to pass at least 11 to nine to
reconsider the vote so I have a motion
to reconsider thank you
second
all right call the roll on the motion to
reconsider okay
um so again we are voting on House Bill
four seven to four seventy four
um
reconsider cell house 474. all right
Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes
representative Prue yes representative
the clerk votes yes representative Stone
yes representative tensar yes
representative gathright yeah
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Vale Ray Newman
representative Newman votes yes
representative Vale Vale votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes
representative wheeler yes
and uh chairman Roy the chair definitely
votes yes this time 20 to 20-0 and the
motion of an expedient to legislate
passes
motion to reconsider
okay let's do this again
now that the motion to reconsider is on
the table it's open for new motions and
I recognize representative Manion
thank you Mr chairman uh my
recommendation is to itl this bill just
so everyone a second any one second
second
represent Pro represent manually speak
to emotion yes thank you Mr chair uh for
clarification I don't know if this
caused some issues with it I am not the
sponsor of this bill even though the
name is the same so I'm going to put
that out to begin with
the section of this bill while I
understand the intent of it is to give
it some teeth I don't think
creating penalties for our local law
enforcement just because they assist or
Aid federal law enforcement in their
duties
penalties up to be felonies paying for
lawyer fees
immediate termination which can cause
some due process issues I don't think
that part of the bill uh I support so it
needs some work and for that reason I
would support an Ito
representative would you like to speak
to you second
I wouldn't say it needs some work I
would say it needs a lot of work
um
that instant firing because
they're required at least to
maybe show up with their blue lights and
is that considered assisting them when
that's part of their Public Safety
duties is to make sure everybody's safe
including the public when these Fire
Federal operations are happening so to
say that we can't go and assist them to
make our people safe
I think with these big fines and
penalties is just
way too far so yep itl
I would I would just add for um like a
real world scenario or the the federal
government raided uh whether you agree
with it or not the home of the former
president and there was a whole
contingent of federal officers that
raided it and the local police because
it attracted a crowd had to keep the
crowd back because even they didn't know
what was going on so under this bill I
believe we would be charging the local
officers because they were there for the
reason that it just it doesn't this does
not make any sense and then to me it it
smacks of some kind of anti-law
enforcement and then I'll never support
that in this committee anyone else
and you can see none please call the
roll this time but the motion is in
experience legislate
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes representative Prue yes
representative Jan Wren I representative
Manion yes the clerk votes US
Representative Stone yes representative
tensar yes representative gathright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes represent represented Sue Newman yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes representative Vale yes
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler and uh
chairman Roy
CE yes
promotion of inexperienced the legislate
carries on unanimous vote of 20-0 and
accept any objection to consent seeing
none you know going consent and I hear
about closed executive session in House
Bill 474 and open the final bill of the
day House Bill 512 and I recognize
foreign
sorry my bad
to pass I'm so used to saying Ito
do I have a second
I'll second it second it by
representative Pratt it's the motion is
ought to pass on the floor right now
um representative would you like to
speak to your motion again this is
another one of those where
um
ATF can kind of change its mind on on
things kind of quickly with no due
process so things that are made in New
Hampshire and don't enter
interstate commerce uh would be exempt
from these laws and rapidly changing
without Rhyme or Reason
uh as long as they stay in New Hampshire
so I I think that's a a pretty good
thing
representative Pratt would you like to
speak to you a second
yes I second this is 174 license gun
manufacturers in New Hampshire I'd like
to support them those are people that
are like you and me working in the state
of New Hampshire and I believe this
would help them in their businesses also
the interstate commerce laws that was
started in 1887 for the railroad have
been overreached for many years in a lot
of areas and this would help protect
that in the state of New Hampshire
thank you
um in my mind this bill is not about
firearm safety whatever side of the
previous bills you come down on this is
about the in my mind the expansion and
growth of the federal government over
every little aspect of our life and our
businesses
the ATF has jurisdiction over firearms
because under the interstate commerce
clause it was found you know by the
court many many years ago that that
qualified and so now they regulate
everything about firearms and one day
they'll say this is legal next day they
say this isn't illegal they're unelected
bureaucrats
having said that
we are protecting one of New Hampshire's
biggest
manufacturers and and sources of revenue
of our fellow citizens who be it a small
um
manufacturer or a huge one
if it's made in New Hampshire and it
stays in New Hampshire it is not by any
definition interstate commerce and
that's what we're trying to protect with
this bill that I open it for discussion
I see representative Newman and I heard
I just want to point out and read the
last part of this bill
because I think it has the same problems
that we just talked about on the
previous bill
it has to do with the penalty any public
servant in the state of New Hampshire is
defined in RSA 640 colon 2 that enforces
or attempts to enforce or act law
statute rule or regulation of the
government of the United States upon a
they shall be guilty of a Class A
misdemeanor and then it goes on to say
that the official agent that that does
the same kind of thing try to to
attempts to enforce act or order a law
statute or rule regulation of the United
States government of the United States
personal firearm and security accessity
manufacturing New Hampshire and the
penalty is a class B felony so I think
you may have law enforcement people
going out to assist the government for
other reasons and I think that the
penalties are
thank you
representative jandron and then the
represent Muse
thank you Mr chairman and again I got a
hot mic so I'll move it to the side
if you look at this sponsor and
co-sponsor you'll see that I'm actually
co-sponsor of this legislation and I
like to explain why
um
it's not a secret I worked at a camp
where I taught Firearms instruction for
two years two summers the two summers I
wasn't in this house
and one of the things that we noticed
early on was
um that our ear protection one was
expensive two uh didn't sometimes get
put into the air by 11 year old boys and
girls that um
even as an instructor we couldn't
confirm that they installed it correctly
one of the things that we had
contemplated in 2021 was to go to a
Farms manufacturer in the state of New
Hampshire and ask them for suppressors
to uh lessen the the report and the uh
Sonic noise of a firearm shot for our
students and we were informed that there
were two ways to do that one was we
would go to the ATF and ask
ask for permission to purchase them
and pay a tax at 200 per device or
and pay that once or we would go and
form an LLC
a point responsible persons
under the atf's regulations
purchased the items that we needed for a
suppression of of the gunfire to save
years and pay 200 blanket every year
thereafter
uh so we looked at a cost benefit
analysis and realized that it was
cheaper to buy earplugs and earplugs
again are not 100 foolproof if the
student is not placing it in their ear
correctly
so
we did approach a firing manufacturer in
the state of New Hampshire I won't
discuss who it was but they are in
Newington
and they do produce suppressors
and they were willing to donate them to
the non-profit camp that I was working
for
and
we decided that cost benefit analysis it
was easier for us to purchase your
protection your earplugs under the cost
benefit analysis because 200 a year may
not sound like a lot to everybody in the
room but for a non-profit it can be
so we admittedly are placing our
students at a disadvantage and maybe a
risk of not having their ear protection
correctly installed
what this bill does is it says if it's
made in New Hampshire
sold in New Hampshire and never leaves
the state of New Hampshire it is not
interstate commerce
I would also argue that
whether it be a non-profit camp that I
work at or a gun shooting range like
white birch or one of these other places
that offer these for rent
making them pay a federal
tax on an item that never leaves the
state of New Hampshire violates the
interstate commerce clause and therefore
is no longer under the jurisdiction of
the United States of America so that's
why I decided that I would support this
bill and become a co-sponsor for it
those are the reasons why I'm supporting
um
experience
foreign
okay
yes
foreign
don't make me pick up this Hammer I
with the sponsor
um I am going to recess this hearing
until next Friday which is the last day
um to act on a bill and I've given him
the opportunity to
um
to make some changes I would encourage
any members to approach him if you would
like to see something or take it in or
put out this is the chance speak now
forever hold your peace
and that being said I close or recess
the hearing and we are finished for the
day
no it's recess and um I appreciate all
the subs coming in today I appreciate
um
representative Reed stepping up to the
plate and again to the members of the
public who sent us those gazillion
emails we did see them I read many of